大家好,我是漆霍琼梦。
第三节课的话跟大家交流了如何做好这个期货开仓。
就像上一节课所提到的一样,我们开仓结果的好坏,包括这个10点的选址,这个点位的选址,那么都会影响到你后面的一个交易心态,从而影响到你这个交易结果。
那么平仓其实跟开仓一样,平仓的一个好坏会直接决定了你的一个交易结果。
那么就跟可能大家都会听到这么一个说法,就是说你会开仓只是交易的一个入满,会平仓才是交易的高手。
那么这句话说的是非常的有道理。
因为如果你去发现的话,多数的时候,我们的钱基本上都是亏在了,不会平仓。
很多时候我们做对的行情,我们都丢掉了,但做出的行情反而我们都能够成功地持有,也就是我们所说的抗当。
那么因为这个原因,所以多数时候我们都是亏钱的,有时候抗的比较厉害,那么你可能亏的就很惨。
平仓的话从结果上来讲,我把它总结为质疑平仓,资存平仓和保稳平仓。
那么多数时候我们会考虑质疑和资本资存。
那么如果一个交易的好坏呢,其实主要的一个,我们刚才说的,就平仓的好坏它决定你的交易的成果。
其实等于是说又换一句话说讲,就是说平仓的好坏,它决定了你赚不赚钱。
我们知道这个平仓结果无非就是赚钱跟亏钱,那么这个结果是很简单,那其实过程是很复杂的。
因为在平仓的一个过程里面,我们要考虑很多因素,包括我们如何去平仓,
什么时候平仓,什么点外平仓,应该平仓多少头寸,那么这些都会影响到你的一个结果,交易的结果。
所以说平仓方式方法选择好与坏,会直接影响着你平仓的一个结果。
我们都知道,我们之所以会考虑会研究这个平仓策略,我们的目的是什么。
其实做交易我也是挺多年了,算起来大概也接近十年的时间,那么吃的亏实在也是很多很多。
有些时候吃的亏真是很刻骨铭心的,我不知道大家有没有一次尝试过亏很多钱,我甚至一个月亏过一百多万,
那么这种吃亏是很刻骨铭心的。
当然我希望多数的交易人物,多数的一个期货交易者都不要去尝试这种亏,真的是承受不起。
所以后面我想一想,我们这个平仓我们的主要目的是什么呢?
最终的目的的话,多数人都知道,那肯定是赚钱。
那么在赚钱之前呢,我们是不是要保证自己能够少吃点亏,保住这个本金,然后慢慢能够多赚点钱,最终才慢慢的把这个钱纪念起来。
所以说其实的话,我们选择这个平仓呢,我们所谓的目的,所谓的目的肯定是保住本金,后面才慢慢的去考虑赚钱。
这里的话用我自己的一个话讲的,我就把它总结成叫做移动平仓策略,也就是说目前我这个交易系统里面,包括我目前的操作,基本上都是按照这个策略来执行这个平仓的。
那么这个平仓是分阶段来做这个平仓策略,就是在开仓阶段和持仓阶段我是怎么去做这个平仓的。
那么开仓阶段的话,因为怎么说呢,开仓阶段的一个目的是保住你的本金,尽量减少本金的亏损。
那么这里所做的一个平仓策略的一个目的就是为了保证我们的本金,尽量减少本金的亏损。
那么持仓阶段的话,主要的就是说在我有盈利的情况下,那么我要稳住我这个福音,那么珍惜这个收益最大化在合理合适的点位去指引,那么保证我们这个收益最大化。
所以呢这个用所以呢就是这里的话就跟大家介绍这个移动平仓策略,那么这个说法呢,是我自己的一个说法。
那么其实跟大家所说的这个移动止损或者移动指引这个说法其实有点大同小异,只不过我为了更好的介绍,所以我这里把它就是归纳成这样子。
那么大概这个我的目的哈就是我跟大家介绍这个移动平仓策略的目的呢,主要就是为了实现这个少吃点亏,多赚点钱这个目的。
那么移动平仓策略的话,刚才说的哈我们是按照阶段来选择这个平仓策略的,那么开仓阶段的话这个平仓策略其实比较简单,在我们那个开仓的时候呢大概也提到了一些。
呃我们的开仓呢为了提高准确率呢我们都通过这个二次回展这种来确认,所以其实啊我们的一个。
开仓的首要目的是保证这本金至少说这个止损成本要尽量的低,所以呢我们的一个开仓策略的开仓阶段的一个平仓策略就是呃在回产的低点。
或者是二百五十日均二百五十均线作为这个平产点位的一个依据气势止损,那么这里的话呃在实际上的操作中我建议大家就是在这个比如我在回产的低点或是高点啊的基础上增加一到两个单位的点位。
那么这个为什么要这么增加呢因为其实你会很发现这个阻力其实的是很狡猾的。
他一般情况下会考虑到多数人都会以这个前低或者前高的点位作为这个止损或者止硬的点位。
所以呢经常会达到这个点位之后呢就是走才走出行情。
所以为了避免这个时候呢刚好被止被止损或者止硬在这个最低或者最高点的时候呢我们适当这个这个在这个点位上我们增加一到两个单位。
那避免被这样子扫出来那么这个是实际上的操作中这个点这个这个点是很重要的。
呃250均线其实也是一样的意思呃那么如果大家其实交易多的话你们都会可能都会发现如果特别是那种呃有做过以前高或者前低为这个止损点位的啊可能都会有这么一个体会。
那么磁场阶段的一个平仓策略呢这里的话呃我基本上就以期货现价以250均线的一个价差还有120均线还有。
250均线作为这个平仓点位的一个一句那么磁场点阶段的一个平仓策略呢其实是最难做的呃有时候呢我们经常会呃。
呃他主观的认为我们的可能这个行情会一直按照我们所想的方向去走但可能多数说呢他不一定会这么顺利。
说的其实我们这个平仓策略呢呃经常会遇到这种呃福音变亏水啊或者福音宝本啊或者大量的一个福音回饰啊都会遇到这个情况。
所以为了保证我因为我们做的本身就是一个波段的一个收益啊那么跟人家做的是长周期的这个收益呢可能没法比。
所以我们为了保证我们的波段收益能尽量的呃拿到手所以我们这里的话必须给大家呃做一个紫银上的一个呃一个考虑啊保证我们的收益先。
那么这里的话因为每个人的一个系统还有这个心态还有呢就是这个承受风格封面等等都不一样。
所以呢这里的话我就不是说强制大家一定要按照这种思路去做但仅仅只是给大家做一个参考。
呃那么这个具体的一个操作是什么样呢呃第一点专业这个价差因为这个价差呢呃价差哈我们之前说的250均线的一个目的呢就是。
当这个期货线价跟这个均线的价差呃偏离过大的时候啊他都有一个回归的一个向心力。
所以如果是说价差出现的快速放大啊并超过近一年最大价差时我建议是前部指引平仓。
因为这个时候等于是说你把这个利润已经提前的锁定了啊那么之后他确实说继续往上走啊那么我们可以再继续在我们这个系统的合适点位我们再去介入。
如果是说这个啊回落到这个合适的点位那么这个时候呢我们再去做啊的等于是说我们是波段滚动那么自家这样会更加实现更大的一种收益。
呃那么至于是不是超过一年最大价差这个跟自己平仲还有个人的一个理解去做啊这里我只是给一个建议因为我目前也是参照一年最大价差去照做的。
啊第二点呢就是当有效下传或上迫120斤线时那么多数磁仓指引平仓啊理由小部分底仓。
因为呢其实我们的250在我们这个系统里面哈250斤线的基本上是作为我们多空的一个分界线啊那么突下传或者上迫120斤线呢那么只是说考虑啊可能这个方向会发生改变了。
那么在这个时候呢我们应该选择考虑先把大部分的头寸先做好指引啊把大部分的利润先锁定起来。
那么有小部分底仓如果是说在跌破这个250120斤线之后往100往250斤线去扣了。
呃那么如果是说250斤线能够有效的支撑或者抵挡住那么这个时候呢我们再考虑去加回我们以来的仓位。
那那么这种操作第三呢就是说当有效下穿或者上迫250斤线时那么全部指引平差啊我刚才已经提到了这个250斤线在我们这个系统里面它就是一个多空分界线。
所以呢这个时候呢我们不要去呃去去去太多的考虑说这个是不是假突破或者真突破啊。
如果是真突破那么我已经全部平常了那等于是我利润已经全部先锁定了如果是假突破没关系。
我们还会按照我们系统呢会有下会有下一个的一个啊进入就是开仓的一个点位和信号那么这个大家都不用急。
所以呢我们这个平常策略呢其实就是呃不会太复杂啊也不会太复杂因为我的目的呢其实就比较简单。
我开仓的目的呃我开仓阶段的目的呢就是为了保证我的本金还有我的一个值损不要太大啊错的情况下啊如果对的情况下你就没有这方面的考虑了。
那么磁仓极端的目的呢很简单就是保证我能够在行轻大的时候呢拿出单啊如果行轻出现这个反方向的我能把我的利润最大化啊这就是我们这个移动平常策略的一个呃目的。
不过呢这里的话就是要提个醒因为我们做的是五分钟周期的一个波段短线交易那么有时候呢可能会出现这个日线级别可能是空头我们在波段里面是做多或者是出现了这个日线是多头我们去做空呃那么这个都有可能啊这个都有可能那么这里的话就是呃。
就会出现这种就是那你这个逆大事气做这个波段的一个一个行情了那这个时候呢我们就要注意了一般情况下如果是说在空头行情里面。
空头行情里面啊那么可能我们五分钟周期的一个一个反一个五分钟周期的一个做多行情那么可能会在上面遇到15分钟一小时日线周线的一个阻力位。
那这个时候呢你就应该适当的做好一部分的一个指引啊保证你一部分的一个收益线那么如果是确实无法啊突破那么你可能就得啊宝贝或者是小部分子就是全部指引出来。
呃同样的如果是说在多头行情里面啊我们去做波段空啊那波段空那你就要留意一下你下面的一个15分钟一小时日线周线的一些支撑位那么如果啊呃在这个支撑位里面呢就建议。
建议都要先考虑部分的指引之后如果是说能够有效突破你再去见过你的一个头寸这个是为了保证自己能够尽量的把这个收益啊拿到手呃。
这里话啊第二点的话其实就是要强调这个自信力的一个重要性了因为我们这个平常呢的依据呢主要是。
低拓这个军线的这个阻力或者支撑位呃你要知道哈就是说呃如果这个支撑或者这个阻力无效了被突破了那么他可能会变成反方反方向的阻力和支撑啊打个比方就比如说啊本来我是上涨的上涨的那么在他回调回落在五五呃二百五十军线的时候啊那我们这个时候呢觉得他阻力呃他这个支撑位。
有效那么我们去产业做多了产业做多了那么这个时候如果哈如果他突然一个呃什么的一个利空消息啊突然让你。
低开或者是一是快速下跌打破了你这个支撑位那这个时候呢你就一定要坚决的进做直损坚决的去做直损平仓呃因为那这个时候呢你这个线就变成了空头的一个阻力位了。
啊空头的阻力位了也就是说你如果没有进行这个对这个多段进行直损的话那么你可能你的多头。
就变成了你在高位接多了高位接多了那么这个对于你后面的操作就很不利啊很不利。
啊很不利所以一定一定一定就是说一定当信号啊当信号发生了跟你的系跟你的系统相反的情况下呢一定要。
坚决的执行这个平仓。
所以说呃执行力对于我们这个平仓侧电是非常重要的呃。
这也是怎么说呢。
当然不管这个执行力呃平仓对平仓的重要性哈大家开仓的时候执行力也是很重要的。
而执行力的这一个说法在我们这个地骨节的人性管理这一块那么会特别特别的强调这一点。
那在后面的话我们再跟大家一起交流分享如何在这个执行力的提高方面啊做一些努力。
呃呃那么这一节课的话其实就是内容的话一样的不会太复杂呃一个交易系统里面我们不需要太复杂啊。
更关键的就是说你们把这些简单的一个能够把这个简单的一些一些一些方法你能够把它固化下来然后间接执行到位那么其实赚钱就不远了。
那么这节课的话我们就简单的分享到这里呃。
那么我就总结一下吧就是这节课的一个目的是什么呢就是为了保证我们这个本金安全至少说减小这个本金的一个question然后能够真尽量的争取到这个更高的收益。
那么这是我们本张这个平衡次列所要讲的一个内容。
那么下一节课的话就会重点的对于像风险管理意思还有这个呃执行力呃提高这个执行力方面呃会进行一个分享。